septembre le mois des vendanges avec ses
vignes dans la vallée du rhône installés
sur des pentes abruptes le dur travail
des saisonniers pour un vin blanc
prestigieux très prisé par les amateurs
didier guyot thierry money la pente est
raide mais depuis des siècles les vignes
sont accrochés à cette terre il est des
coteaux escarpés qui sont bénis des
dieux la dorian est de ceux là
c'est sur les hauteurs de condrieu un
lieu où les romains déjà avait planté
des vignes que c'est la bourse blanc au
bout incomparable et partir ça va pas
trop chaud les hommes souffrent lavigne
aussi juste ce qu'il faut le sol est
aride orientation plein sud
qu'importe c'est ici que le cépage
viognier offre ses plus beaux réseaux
l'important évidemment ce raisin c'est
de le faire pousser sur un solde
particulier essentiel terroir c'est le
mariage du terroir avec le raisin qui va
donner aux vagues toute sa rage toute sa
noblesse
toutes ces particularités chats créé un
compte et il se doit d'être
irréprochable il faut donc le trier avec
soin et ne laisser passer aucune
mauvaise nourriture le vigneron a
travaillé toute l'année pour cela d'un
grand moment d'émotion parce que c'est
le fruit d'une année de travail dans les
vignes
c'est un travail quotidien ou mis un
petit peu trop parce que bon on pense
aux raisins pendant les vendanges
la bim sa compagne et c'est ainsi que le
vin a sommeillé neuf mois en fût de
chêne avant d'être mis en bouteille
la robe dorée les parfums somptueux la
pêche côtoient les fruits exotiques qui
vont jaillir explosé en dehors du verre
avec désarroi des arômes
caractéristiques que sont la pêche
blanche et l'abricot relever ici dans le
condrieu la dorian avec des nuances
boisé la dorian s'étend sur deux
hectares et va donner naissance à
seulement huit mille bouteilles trop peu
aux dires des amateurs